the ultimate guessing trick is a way to
solve single selection questions even if
you have no clue what the correct answer
is the key is that exactly one of the
choices is correct and the others will
be similar to it but they can be
eliminated in turn looking at these four
choices only one of them has three x
cubed so right away we can eliminate
this answer choice
then of the remaining three answer
choices only one of them has two x
squared so we eliminate this answer
choice we are down to b and c
now focus on 11x 13 which is similar in
answer choices a and c
this makes b the outlier and we
eliminate answer choice b
we are left with answer choice c and
that is the correct answer this strategy
works best if you have no clue there's
no penalty for guessing and you have
extra time to fill in some blanks the
downside is it takes a lot of time so if
you're good enough to apply this
strategy you're probably good enough to
just prepare for the test and solve it
because that is an age-old technique
that works almost every time